I don't know how you do all this
literally Saturday night you're hosting
one charity event Sunday you're here why
is it so important for you to make the
time in your busy schedule to come to
events like this and to support these
causes oh I would love to meet people
who go I don't have time for that that
would be great
well yesterday was one of my closest
friends Gayle Cohen Braun who created
the the F Cancer gala and in foundation
and she was getting the vanguard award
and asked me to present it to her so you
know um when you have amazing friends
who do amazing things you have to you
know step up them and and of course
something like this you know it's
amazing you know organization for the
United Nations and garlic to be able to
receive this it's incredibly humbling
and you know it was a big surprise as
well how did you react when you got that
call it's the first one in the word hero
that's such a big word um yeah you know
uh it was surprising you know because
you know usually when you speak out
you're anticipating a negative blowback
kind of what happens but with an award
like this it's just really reassuring to
see where we're at in the world right
now that instead of negative
consequences there are people that hear
you that care and and are helping you to
make real change in the world when you
look back at even the past year I mean
the things you've revealed the things
that you've spoken out about how has
that changed you um well you know I've
I've always spoken out even privately um
you know my situation I came out with
Brett Ratner was a bit different than a
lot of the other space them up because
um in 2010 I had written a book and I
had written chapter about it and I
disguised him in it for legal reasons
and then the next year on his own
volition he um claimed himself in that
book and then he went on to lie about me
and then just a few days after that he
went on to the Howard Stern Show and
admitted that he lied about me and that
was in 2011 and he admitted that he lied
about all the things that he said about
me and
but still you know he's claiming this
part of the book that was this horrible
thing that he had done and then just a
few years later he gets this huge you
know a few hundred million dollar
financing deal with Warner Brothers so
you know back then people it wasn't that
long ago and people didn't care he
admitted to it people left it off and
they keep going and he keeps getting
bumped up higher and higher into these
positions of authority in power
privately I would always talk about it
and I would always tell people and I
would even you know I'd be in meetings
with producers and directors and studio
people who I knew worked with them and I
would always ask them you know why do
you work with why do you work with him
so I was never quiet and I've never been
really the kind of person that you can
silence that's how I've been my whole
life was I was a kid and that's how I've
always been but this last year the the
difference in you know in like just like
seven years right like in 2011 he was
able to admit to these things lie about
me you know try to defame me and then
keep you know getting more powerful and
now I'll send this past year as a
consequence and you can't hurt women
you can't disrespect them you can't keep
turning blind eyes and and allowing this
kind of abuse to go on and and that's
just you know I still try to figure out
and like what do I feel about that
because it's just such a strange place
to be that people care but instead of
trying to figure out why or how I feel
about it I'm just extremely grateful and
I want us to all just keep moving
forward a long time coming too long yeah
I mean there's a lot of justices in the
world and you know this is one of them
and I'm just I'm really grateful to all
the women who actually and men like um
Anthony Rapp and Terry Crews but a lot
of women like Jessica Bharath moon carry
class and klieg who all spoke out and
and we're the true science breakfast you
know the ones who created this entire
movement from the beginning the names
that we know we don't always hear
they're not household names but they
should be because they are the real
heroes because it takes a lot to to
speak out and and to name a name and to
and have your name out there with that I
just admired you so much with everything
with predator because that was such a
big movie and you saw something that was
wrong and you did something about it
where do things stand with you and the
cast because I know you'd studied felt
kind of isolated by them how are things
now I'd get all of the main cast members
we've all had conversations and we've
all talked and you know I understand
that it's a situation that you know for
I understand for a lot of people they
don't know what to do for me it just was
very obvious I think that you know it's
a it's a hard situation I understand
that they were you know you know they
froze and we've all had those talks and
they're all really good guys you know
they they you know they're not the bad
guys in the situation at all you know it
was important I think for people to see
and to understand to hear that you know
how it all played out that I you know
that there was an isolation that was
going on because you know what happened
to me
um with the isolation and feeling
ostracized I mean that is literally a
drop in the ocean compared to what so
many girls go through when they call out
somebody if they are calling out and the
star quarterback on the team and now the
whole town turns against them and we've
hear so many of these stories and we
don't know their names and they're not
you know um headline news everywhere but
they should be because you know they
know that feeling and they know what
times you know a thousand so everything
I went through I you know I'd very
quickly one piece of advice you'd give
to your younger self because we've got a
lot of girls out there today my mom used
to say that I was um - growing up she
feel like you're so stubborn why do you
always talk back and
um the other day she called me and and
she said oh man you know it's on the
headline news in Hong Kong and Vietnam
and I can't believe it everyone's
talking about it and you know I just
have to say I'm um I'm very happy I
never told you to shut up oh no that's
what I was on my younger self but like
you know I'd say like don't shut up
don't shut up you know what you're
losing your voice today but it's because
you're speaking so loudly
[Music]